this video sponsored by Legal Zoom more
on Legal Zoom at the end of the video
what's up everyone
Jared again here a wisecrack we adore
Assassin's Creed Ubisoft hallmark series
combines our love for history science
fiction and fast-paced action all into
one package sure some games have been
hilariously glitchy and depressingly
underwhelming but overall the series has
remained a steadfast favorite of ours so
when many of you asked for a philosophy
a video we were really really tempted
but there's just one major problem while
the games include historical titans like
Machiavelli and Benjamin Franklin
there's really not much in the way of
philosophy here of course there's the
Assassin's mantra nothing is through
everything is generated but no matter
how far we dive into the series this
idea is never really developed through
the plot instead it's more or less just
lip service that serves as a background
for a game about killing popes redcoats
pirates and so on yeah it is insanely
fun this slightly changes with the
arrival of the Assassin's Creed movie
unlike the rest of the series the vague
philosophy of everything is permitted
has no gameplay to hide behind and when
the movie tries to make sense of this
mantra don't I stop I'm with you well it
doesn't quite work so sit back and let
us tell you the story of how a 1939
Slovenian novel became the philosophical
backbone for Assassin's Creed sorta
welcome to his wise crack Edition on
Assassin's Creed what went wrong mostly
the movie and of course spoilers ahead
nothing is true everything is permitted
if you played any of the games you've
heard this phrase and it probably got
your philosophy cent tingling to explain
how this mantra makes little sense in
the game and no sense in the movie we
first have to consider where the game
lifted it from vladimir Bartles
relatively obscure book ala mode as it
turns out Alamut is the most translated
Slovenian text in the world and honestly
we can't recommend it enough it is a gem
full of rich characterization and deep
philosophy the novel centers around the
eponymous Iranian castle of Alamut in
the 11th century controlled by the
smiley prophet Hassani Sabbah while it
smiley ism is a real
branch of Shia Islam and that's on a
real historical figure Bartol chose to
fictionalize bow in the book Hassan's
followers believe he possesses the
literal keys to paradise but Hassan
himself believes only in rational
thought and empirical truth in order to
control his followers he deceives them
by drugging them with opiates and
delivering them to artfully constructed
gardens and harems meant to emulate
heaven in doing so Hasan has created a
fervent army of hosh oisin or as we know
them today
assassins Hassan's guiding belief
nothing is true everything is permitted
this mantra is the supposed
philosophical underpinning of the entire
Assassin's Creed franchise see the
series explores the age-old conflict
between two ideologically opposed
fictionalized groups the assassins and
the Knights Templar whereas the
assassins venerate free will the
Templars are obsessed with enslaving
mankind to this end the groups vie for
control over the apples of Eden remnants
of a lost higher civilization that
supposedly contain the origins of man's
free will
the assassins want to safeguard the
apples while the Templars want to use
them to make mankind obey their will we
have a similar situation play out in the
film when convicted murderer Callum
Lynch wakes up in the Abstergo
foundations laboratory a modern day
front for the Templars with the help of
a machine called the Animus Kadeem how
must relive the life of his 15th century
ancestor an assassin named Aguilar and
find the Apple for such a rich concept
one might be wondering why the
Assassin's Creed film is such a train
wreck or why the original trilogy of
Assassin's Creed games had such an
underwhelming ending while many of you
might chock it all up too bad writing
just open than you but you'll explain
the ticket which is definitely part of
it we think there's something more going
on say the series never flushes out the
assassins motivations or what really
lies behind their conflict with the
Templars these issues are really just
symptoms of a larger problem the
franchise is confused handling of the
philosophy behind Alamut first of all
where Alamut
sees this mantra being spouted by a guy
trying to enslave people assassin's
creed decides to assign it to the
assassins
who are allegedly fighting for freedom
and it's not exactly an uplifting code
to live by especially for the supposed
good guys mind we found nothing is proud
limited immorality along everything if
this seems extreme to you that's because
this on the surface seems like an
argument for moral nihilism in which all
moral judgments are false because
there's no underlying truth to them it
believes in nothing Lebowski nothing
want to push grandma down the stairs
sure go right ahead nothing matters
although the franchise uses this quote
to establish a conflict between free
will and slavery that's not what this
quote is referring to if the whole
everything is permitted things strikes
you as a belief that a villain should
hold well there's good reason for that
it comes from Hassani Sabbah the Ismaili
prophet and chief antagonist of Alamut
hasan is ultimately a tragic figure
a man whose intellect and ambition have
robbed him of happiness taking a page
from descartes hasan believes that
emotions truth and even god are all
misunderstandings born out of man's
imperfect senses this crippling
realization leaves him feeling empty and
alone the only thing that can make him
feel alive again is gam during his own
faith in the fate of others which is why
he built his army so hasan nothing is
sacred and therefore there's nothing he
won't do in his pursuit of power so what
does Hasan do once he discovers that
nothing is true he comes to the
conclusion that religion is just the
intentional manipulation of the masses
for their own good
prophets like Moses Jesus and Mohammed
recognized man's frailty and out of pity
crafted concepts such as heaven and
paradise to comfort them
mankind according to Hassan cares
nothing for justice or truth only their
own comfort and convenience consequently
he believes that he's entitled to use
religion deceive and control his
followers and in the process do good by
them now the problem here is that this
is the exact credo of the Templars
control the masses for the
own good even though it's the assassins
that are parroting Hassan's motto these
muddled motivations may not matter too
much in a game but it ends up really
mattering in a movie where the audience
needs a clear division between
protagonist and antagonist and at the
end of the day why are the assassins
they're good guys aside from the
cult-like ritual that opens the film and
the constant repetition of their
one-line philosophy the assassins
Brotherhood isn't explored as an
organization at all after a two-hour
film we don't know anything more about
them than what we learned from the
floating text given to us at the movies
start the Templars are bad and the
assassins are trying to stop them this
is the only way the movie tries to
convince us that the assassins are the
good guys by making sure we know that
the Templars are definitely the villains
and boy are the Templars evil here is a
secret ancient organization disguised as
the multi-billion dollar of stereo
corporation it's got all the trappings
of an elite build a supergroup a modern
concrete facility complete with white
halogen lights higher-ups who refer to
themselves as elders I work as long as
the elders some cookie cutter lines
about controlling the masses the threat
remains why Free Will exists and a
leader played by Jeremy Irons so once
again the Templars are bad but why are
the assassins good this is the question
we keep coming back to and it goes back
to the philosophy in forming the
conflict between assassins and Templars
because as the movie revealed the two
are ideologically very similar both
sides are just reflections of Hassani
Sabbah ideology although we're being a
little generous to the assassins here
since the movie doesn't really bother to
give them a clear motivation outside the
motto they lifted from the song in the
film we see the Templars controlling the
masses just like Hassan did they used
the Spanish Inquisition as a front to
solidify their power and commit some
truly heinous crimes rating houses
murdering innocents and torching people
alive Hassan did the same thing using
the east Miley doctrine to create a
fanatical army that literally tortures
its captured enemy and while the Templar
is no longer use religion to control the
masses they use something else a
corporation
we try with religion and politics and
now consumerism to eliminate dissent
that's right
Templars control the masses through
consumerism and ease of life but even
this is another reflection of Hassan's
dangerous philosophy the supreme
commander of the smiley faith frequently
compares his religion to a machine one
which turns food shelter and comfort
into its deadly army having both a
protagonist and an antagonist with the
same motivations isn't just boring it's
plain bad of course as the movies cheap
source material but games are guilty of
this as well and perhaps nowhere is this
more evident than in Assassin's Creed 3
in the game Desmond Miles has escaped
control of Abstergo but is still using
the animus to access the memories of its
18th century ancestor Haytham Kenway for
the first couple of hours of the game we
go through all the familiar motions
climbing on buildings stabbing people
with our hidden blade and chatting with
our comrades about how the order is
going to make the world a better place
the twist
well this order is actually the order of
the Templars like yup Haytham is
actually a Templar but because the
Assassin's ideology and their motto is
so vague we couldn't tell the difference
between whether we were playing a
Templar or an assassin or in the first
game desmond is forced to relive the
memories of his 12th century ancestor
altai air even la alta air is a
high-ranking assassin who disgraces
himself it is forced to redeem himself
by assassinating high-ranking Templars
the twist here is that all tires boss
and the leader of the assassins al
mualim has been working with both the
assassins and the Templars to acquire
the apple of Eden for himself like the
chapter with Kenway this shows us how
ideologically indistinct the assassins
are without any real moral or
ideological substance behind their motto
al Moline was able to convince the
assassins and the player to kill his
enemies by simply labeling them as
Templars it's almost as if the assassins
here were like the Ismaili faith being
manipulated by Hasan except they
inexplicably hold the same view nothing
is true everything is permitted
so here's the big question guys and gals
we have a franchise whose central
conflict is kind of a mess so why do we
love scaling some of the tallest
buildings across Europe in the middle
while we nearly pull our hair out
watching Fassbender deliver another
uninspired line well the best we can
come up with is the difference an agency
between films and video games and films
were not active participants so it's
mainly the narrative that keeps us
interested share our choreography
lighting set design and a whole host of
other factors keep us tuned in but
ultimately it's the story that we watch
for as such films mostly live and die by
the quality of their narratives whether
it's the Shawshank Redemption or the B
movie a film primarily succeeds by
having a dynamic protagonist whose
journey has a beginning middle and end
video games however are different
because we play them they don't need a
story to be engaging as long as the
gameplay mechanics are enjoyable wonder
how a game like flappy bird can become a
worldwide sensation overnight generating
50,000 dollars a day in revenue simple
stupidly addictive gameplay which means
were naturally more forgiving when a
video games lifts up don't want to watch
the plot unfold push a skip the cutscene
and go back to slashing probes this is
why we think the Assassin's Creed
franchise stands up so well as a game
when it falls right on its face as a
film in the movie we couldn't care less
about Cal or Aguilar scaling buildings
or assassinating priests precisely
because the film doesn't bother to
create an engaging narrative to hook us
would I rather watch to emotionally
dead-eyed characters hop between
buildings like a Chinese Acrobat or
would I rather control a character and
do it myself
I think the choice here is obvious so
while the game will forever remain a
favorite of ours we think we'll pass if
they ever make another Assassin's Creed
movie until next time stay good guys
peace although conflicts that don't
really make sense can ruin a movie
making sense of your legal work is a
hundred percent essential LegalZoom is
the smart way to handle all your legal
needs whether you're setting up a new
business or planning family matters
they'll help you breeze through the
process like that and LegalZoom is
giving wisecrack fans 15% off their
purchase LegalZoom eliminates the
guesswork of trying to find an attorney
you trust wondering how much your legal
work will cost having to take
unnecessary trips to a lawyer's office
meaning you'll also avoid those
painfully out of date time magazines
zoom works with a network of independent
attorneys to help you with all sorts of
projects the formation of your company
wills and trusts trademarks and patents
contracts and more when we decided to do
wisecrack full-time the most important
step was making sure our business was
set up right
separating personal stuff from the
company and navigating all the
intricacies of state and local laws can
be a huge pain not to mention figuring
out how to trademark our logo but
LegalZoom offers the services and
resources to make sure you get it done
right so gather your business copyright
and trademark and family planning
questions and head over to legalzoom.com
slash wisecrack at the link in the
description below you'll get 15% off
your purchase just for being a fan of
what we do
thanks to Legal Zoom for sponsoring this
video that's all for now wisecrack don't
forget to subscribe and help us get to 2
million subscribers and ring that Bell
so you don't miss a thing
you